but watch i mean especially this one kid
in the blue shirt comes and kicks it
and he's just like look spitting on it
they're spitting on the statue they're
going up to it look this guy kicks it
that guy watch this guy in the blue
t-shirt watches
it's the worst kick i've ever seen you
can see it's kind of it's like
you can see his chubby belly in his
t-shirt and yeah
he kicks the statue he looks like mosh
boy he does look like we got
with the way he gets his foot up but the
way he kicks the statue
like there's so much resistance like
he's got so little muscle in his leg
like look at that woman in the black
this this is
killing it she's yeah she's kicking her
yeah
she's slowly kicked out his kicks are
really
lame you know why because he's he's very
conscious of how heavy that statue
probably is and he doesn't want to hurt
his foot
yeah you can tell he's like at the last
minute he's like backing off of it
because if you look at when he first
kicks the statue it looks like the
statue kicks him back
like he goes up he jumps up he kicks the
statue and then he like springs
backwards like he didn't realize that
this was a
a cast iron structure
and there it goes oh it broke it bent
when it fell that'd be so cool to watch
it break though awesome
and i don't even it's not about like oh
good racism is dead it's about like
how crazy statue breaking yeah cool man
a big thing that grown-ups put up there
we broke it
uh i want to see the little fat kid
jumping they're throwing their shoes out
oh he's stopped
just heel kicked it yeah but i mean he's
busy playing his cool guitar oh yeah
can they spray pam on it first they show
that they sprayed oil on it
i guess the people who wanted to protect
it i'm thinking so you couldn't get a
grip on it
oh so you put cooking spray on it i saw
some article where they put
cooking spray on i'm guessing that's
what it was for just squirting ky jelly
all over it
slip and slide would you have laughs at
this person pushing the statue didn't
realize that the base was attached to it
and fell off with it and broke their leg
how awesome would it be if the statue
fell
on top of the person like if the person
and the statue just fell back at the
same time
look at that there goes the statue oh
smashy smashy oh his head got smashed in
too
the head fell off that'd be fun to see
and then they spit on it like oh the
statue
shut up flipping off the statue
[Laughter]
and he fixes his hand the guy's playing
a song and
this kid is out of breath what is he
playing the kid in the blue shirt that
tried to kick the statue is out of
breath he's got the
oh and he went to spank it till he
smacked it oh he hates racism look at oh
my leg i hate racism so much
oh and he fixes his hair like i'm cool
i'm cool all right watch him again this
is the worst kick and then he goes to
smack it he fix his shirts or his fat
stomach doesn't show here he goes
oh oh i hate racism racism gets a kick
from me
yeah you're not going to be racism on my
watch
no racist statues are going to be here
no racist statues are safe when i'm
kicking them here goes
my this is a great kick i'll leave trips
around this
he does the only sound that i i can
picture because there's no sound
on this video unfortunately but when i
see him bounce off the statue
i all i hear is that woman on the news
goes
and he kicks the bass so lame my
favorite part is him just standing there
after he kicks i'm cool i'm cool
because you know he's just so
uncomfortable in his own skin and he has
so much anger at racism he's going to
give this statue a second
kick that means nothing hates racism
i think i got this chick with the
pigtails who's just kicking the [ __ ] out
of it
someone tells me she's kicking somebody
from 15 years ago oh yeah
[ __ ] you dad lick your breath lick her
breath lick her breath lick her breath
and she's like kicking with her toe like
she's yeah she's not using her bottom of
her foot she's like actually kicking
like a ball
it looks like uh it looks like the kid
in the blue shirt in his first kick
it looked like he's wearing like canvas
sneakers and he went to kick it but he
doesn't know how to kick because he's
done nothing physical in his life
so he went to kick it and he kicked with
like the top of his foot and i think it
hurt his toes sure i think so too
because he's stuck he kind of hops
stumbled
and then he kicks with the top the
bottom of his foot watch the lame kick
on the top
with the bottom of his foot just comes
down like he's stepping on it like he's
squat
uh he's like i'm taking a photo no more
photo ow ow
wow he skips away he did that take a
photo first didn't he
he did he took a photo and then he
skipped away and now he's
he's out of breath he's totally out of
breath watch him fixing his shirt though
you do that thing when your little tummy
is showing
and you don't want it to show where you
fluff your shirt watch him fluff his
shirt watch him fluff his shirt
don't want my tummy to show watch he
fixes his hair let's see let's see
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait there it
is
your shirt clings to your belly and
titties do you think it was a good kick
the second one
it was the worst kick ever he hates
racism though
imagine if you hate racism how lame you
feel if a racist
a broken racist statue beat you up i
wish we could get this guy on the phone
i would love to i know if he didn't hurt
himself too but he'll be in the hospital
he might be
he might he might be i would disown him
if i was family
if i were that kid's dad i'd be on
facebook like that that
kick he did not learn that kick putting
out a statement an official statement
yeah i don't know
no he is not welcome until he learns how
to kick like a man
i think this is an unfair competition i
would make that girl that
that girl was kicking the [ __ ] out of
the statue i'd make her my news she's
pretty awesome
she's badass she's kicking the [ __ ] out
of it and sir uh joe in las vegas i want
to see we get more footage from this i
would love to see
more of that second kick that this video
stops
ow the second can't wait to get to a
second joe look at this guy look at this
guy he's
he's with his guitar he's like i could
take a minute to start playing guitar to
just heal kick this statue
and that woman put her hands on it and
people are spitting on it they're
spitting on the statue oh i want to see
him spanx about to punch it yeah
spank it with his hand boo oh what a i
spanked racism
what a total [ __ ] what a dork hey
what's up joe in las vegas
i'm on the radio what's up boys hey man
jimmy i hope to see you when you come to
vegas
but look i think i think uh my main my
main point is
so you can go back and look at isis
destroying ancient monuments right
and and we're all outraged by that
because it's old history but i'm sure
those guys did some horrific [ __ ]
back in the day but it's history right
so i mean history's history so i i don't
really
know what my point is i know what you're
saying but it's a little different isis
who's beheading people this is just
people think an awful part of
my statue shouldn't be a public monument
to something there's a difference
there's also first world problems though
right
a little bit now it's kind of addressing
it's a legacy of slavery
which is an embarrassing part of our
country i i don't think it's necessarily
a first world
slavery going on right now in the world
it's a problem sure
right yeah i just wish that yeah i mean
we have a different
outrage but uh i believe i actually
believe the outrage on this one people
are going to be outraged by
more about slavery in their country than
in another country if you live in the
south
and you see these monuments to these
guys it probably is irritating to see
and i do believe you're disgusted with
it if you're like these guys were racist
they were fighting to keep racism why
are we
why is there another angle sorry so we
found a better angle this like there's a
prudence
it really is he kicked back and he comes
to the left here he comes here he comes
from the side watch oh god damn it this
[ __ ] guy
all right thank you joe thank you guys i
want to watch him he kicks back
and to the left he punches it and every
video that i've seen
cuts it off right before i could see how
hard he actually puts his fist to it
there's
no way he punches if he punches it with
with even
ten percent strength there's going to be
some video evidence of him like holding
his fingers after
something i think he's calm down he hit
it with his palm ah
oh let's watch more videos of this
definitely there has to be footage of
him
it's a bunch of it's it's mainly white
kids
getting real pissed off and tearing down
a
a statue in what state was this again
travis north carolina was in
durham north kakalaki
and and yeah i would say get rid of
confederate statues but
i would leave it to the city to get rid
of them i guess i would encourage the
city to get rid of them i don't i don't
i'm tired of the dixie flag
celebrating that [ __ ] [ __ ] point of
view that they had back i'm talking
about the slavery point of view yeah
i am too but i do i worry because i feel
like
if if you know the snowflakes and the
social justice warriors take it upon
themselves to remove these statues
they're gonna get hurt they're not the
they're not the
greatest athletes in the world no the
last thing i want to do is see somebody
break a toe
because they're trying to kick a robert
e lee statue or something
yeah we have to find more footage of
this kid i know i wish isn't he a gem
he's phenomenal he's all he's
wait wait go back i saw him again i did
too he was he was really he was really
outraged
he was trying to like fight against a
crowd it was yeah it was there he is
[ __ ] you statue but he went to help pull
it it was already being toppled
look at how late to the game he is i saw
it i saw exactly wait
wait go back it's it's the statue he
grabs the rope that everybody's grabbing
so they have a yellow like rope around
the statue and they're all going to pull
it together to knock the statue down
and there's like probably seven or eight
people all together pulling this rope so
the statue falls
and just as the statue is already
tilting so it's exactly what we were
talking about a minute ago
like you see the weight distribution has
changed so you know
the statue is now falling for short he
jumps on the end
it was already the statue was already
head over heels
and then he jumps over so we can tell
when he pulled it down yeah i pulled the
statue down and then i kicked it
actually my toe kind of hurts he did
look at him he runs over i got it yeah
it was
he wasn't needed so he but he wants to
believe like if he were to look at that
footage
there he is he would believe that he
was the final he was the last piece of
the puzzle to end racism
here's what he's gonna say we pulled it
down what he should say they pulled it
down
right he's in every shot he believes
that he is the power
he is that one remaining peace they're
like there's so many of us
why can't we destroy racism and he goes
because you haven't found me get off
your bullet
and it goes down he didn't help there
no he didn't help at all he wasn't if he
literally never showed up
not one thing would have been different
it would have been exactly the same the
only thing that would have been
different is
less bruised toes yeah and less
enjoyment of watching this video
oh yeah yeah this story would have been
about a step here's what he did
by being so silly and uncoordinated he
made
this this symbolic gesture more about
what a dope he is yeah and hilarious
yeah because
how bad he was at kicking and beating a
statue right right like i think racism
is still the same wait hold on here's
another angle he stepped on wait let's
see him palm hit him yeah
oh he kicks it again then he walks away
he walks away he's like okay i've had
enough
i'll let everybody know he's still there
does he come back i hope so he's yelling
oh i'd love to know what he was yelling
oh he fixes his hair too of course he
does i'm cool
i'm cool guys don't worry about me i
might know he was yelling ow
ow ow racism hurts
he's also like if you look at where he's
positioned in every shot
everybody has their little clicks within
this group of uh
of young people that are against racism
everybody has their little clicks right
like everybody has their uh their
friends and their groups and stuff yeah
he's by himself
he's a loner he's not hanging out with
anybody i want to see a better angle of
the palm hit that he puts on the statue
and that blue t-shirt though he looks
like violet beauregard after chewing the
gum
yes he's not he's not a real specimen
oh this is what people should be talking
about today yeah this is what the news
should be covering
this little chubby kid chubby boy can't
kick
in south carolina or north carolina
wherever it was oh this is steve come on
i
understand we're gonna make a million
steve in florida
hello hello steve hi guys
hi all right you sound like you're
annoyed already but
no no i'm not annoyed necessarily your
point but it's it's more like
we we take everything and we try to why
isn't this well how come it and like
sometimes something is just in itself
what you're talking about but go ahead
all right well obviously you know no one
looks at the nazi flag and says hey
that's a great thing except for people
who have mental problems
we all know what happened you know
during world war ii but
you know you got these antifa guys
carrying soviet flags
the old hammer and sickle and there
doesn't seem to be any real
outrage about that when all things
considered they were just as bad
that is true why are they carrying the
soviet flag and they actually kill more
people than the uh
i guess maybe just because the
concentration camps are targeted the
jews i i don't have an answer for that
but why are they carrying soviet flags
when people are
mad at the russians for apparently
interfering and getting trump elected
and yet these people like the soviets so
much doesn't make sense they don't like
the soviets i think the the flag is a
symbol of like communism and socialism
it's a symbol of communism and socialism
which you know after the bolsheviks took
over they killed
tens of millions of people in their own
country during the purges they also went
after jews
in uh pogroms i mean the the chechnyans
they tried to exterminate them
i'm with you i think you know antifa or
whatever they're called as scumbags too
they're absolutely and they're you know
they're children with no real
understanding of how awful communism is
right exactly awful it is to live under
that system because they've got a lot of
them have gotten most of what they've
wanted
in their lives yes they have no idea how
awful it is to be told by the government
what to think and what to feel and
exactly how much you can have and how
much you can't have thank you for the
cost actually you made some points there
steve so they're like when you're oh
thank you when you're in fifth grade and
you first get explained what communism
is in like a social studies class
and when it first gets explained to you
in principle you're like oh yeah
if everybody wins why don't we do that
sure and then it takes
you know two lessons to figure out why
it
never works and it's always corrupted
and bastardized
and you're right i mean antifa doesn't
or what i don't
am i saying the name right auntie yeah
where's he's laughing because there's
more footage of fatty dropping a sign
we have a new angle oh okay never mind
so yes the uh
the the antique is a bunch of idiots
yeah they're a bunch of douchebags
um this is great because i would like to
know what happened to this statue though
let me see troy
there you go no no tell me what no he
holds up the sign and he has the sign
going
and he sees the statue already coming
down and he throws the sign down and
runs over
and he's this is where the action is so
not only does he not help he litters
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so he's got first of all he's the dork
that made the sign the night before
like he didn't make it there because
he's he's the only guy that's got one of
those wooden planks
on the back of his sign so you could
hold it up with like a handle
like the way you would watch on like a
television show protesters do something
yeah like he's picketing
and then he does the minute he sees the
statue is about to fall
he runs over well he waddles over
because he's not in the greatest shape
and he throws his he just throws his
sign down face first on the floor
and just pretends like he's the last
little bit of pull
that's going to get rid of this racist
statue oh
it's great little chubby guy it's great
hey we should find out who he is
can't come in tonight i'm protesting i'm
i'm ending racism there should be a uh
a twitter account called yes you're
[Laughter]
unhealthy
i stopped racism at comic con yeah
someone said i remember the clan holder
confirmed oh god the confederate flag
the confederate flag is so stupid
because
i don't i i just i just don't understand
how it's like
like they were against
american now is the america that won the
civil war right
that's why we became america so the
confederacy is against the ideals of
america they wanted to not be a part of
america right right they didn't like uh
well some of our ideals right so we went
to war with them
and then they lost and we won even in
the south now you're not
in the confederacy anymore you won
congratulations
you're all part of america now and also
the clan embraces that flag
the clan embraces that flag so if you're
into the dixie flag it's like that's the
flag that the clan way like come on man
just let it go right it's a shitty
symbol and it's not like it symbolizes
shitty stuff just let it go
it's not like erase it from from history
and take it off the [ __ ] dukes of
hazzard car that's all stupid stuff
it's it's it's just right now
stop waving it around as if it's your
flag they could try to take it out of
history
eventually no but i mean but i mean it
did exist and you shouldn't any more
than you should remove the nazis from
history
you have to teach what happened and what
and be accurate about it
and i don't like revision revisionist
history either what about those books
that came out that they they take out
the n-word that was in there
that's stupid that's stupid it's stupid
but they're do it they do it
i know there's something a lot of things
that are stupid right it shouldn't be
done it shouldn't be done that's what
we're not advocating for
i think jim and i are both of the
opinion that the confederate flag is
just
dumb at this point not honoring
something and not not waving it as if it
still has relevance
is different than erasing it from
history i don't think the confederacy
should be erased from history
no i don't think those soldiers their
memories should be disgraced at all they
were
fighting for what they believe in i do
think that they should not be
necessarily honored for that point of
view
but i don't think that they should be
disgraced or wiped from history right
like
what if you just stop acting like it's
an ongoing thing just stop acting like
it's a big part of your culture today
it's not
yeah and then let it be in history i'll
bet people would leave it alone in
history
if people weren't like waving around
today have you ever seen
somebody that guy kicked that statue
and hold on to the flag so much like
it's like you get beat up by
it's embarrassing let it go yeah but to
be fair i've seen the opposition get
beat up by a statue
so i don't know i don't know which side
i land on at this point
i found it you found what i found
punching the thing
no no no you didn't you couldn't have
it's even better
than i had hoped oh my god email a
detroit oh please do
are you excited to come of course dude
it's all i want to see
i must have watched a hundred of these
videos this is the reason why you didn't
take a sick date today norton
yeah hang on i'm saying troy has his
email open right now just waiting just
like that's right just like
rubbing his hands together like he's in
a [ __ ] nascar
pit crew just ready to move move move
testification this is
so bad this is did he hit it the way i
thought he did with his palm
just watch you you could skip a little
you know where oh
[Applause]
dario okay oh boy this angle yeah let's
watch from here okay there he goes he's
he stumbles across the statue after he
kicks it because he hurt himself
there's that chick kicking the [ __ ] out
of the statue i like her
okay and then here's the here's the
here's the i mean there he goes he
he gets the t-shirt cling off of his fat
[Laughter]
belly
what he did we should tweet that video
out he thought better of it
he goes he goes down he bends down to
punch the statue
and then right before he hits the statue
he stops and then he backs away
he lets some other tough guy hit the
statue and then he kicks it
kicks it again oh my god this is
wonderful i want to watch
oh my god
he's so uncoordinated
he's winded oh yes he is exhausted oh
those little
soft kicks kick
butt no
[Laughter]
oh that's great that's great i love it
they're all there [ __ ] you what's he
doing now is there more
oh it's play a little let's see what
else he does he's got the arm up
he's got his arm up but he's winded man
he is exhausted that was good fine
travis
i'm so happy i found it he's he's
excited is that better than you thought
yep well think about it think about how
tired he is
within the frame of about 75 seconds
he was holding a sign up in the air
right then he had to throw the sign down
run over pretend to pull a statue down
then run over to the statue kick it hurt
his foot
then run away from the statue then run
back to the statue
pretend like you're going to punch it
and then kick it again i mean that's
going to exhaust anybody god i love that
he didn't punch it
his little chubby hand just stopped it
is chubby right
oh he's just so and i love that angle of
his yeah
his back that's it's literally mosh girl
it really is he almost
fell into the person who's holding the
camera at this thing can't get over this
woman
kicking the [ __ ] out of it oh she's got
so much anger she's not happy about that
today i guarantee it
yeah that foot hurts look he's just big
fixes his hair again damn i'm angry i
hate racism i'm out of shape
and then this chick goes back over [ __ ]
that statue
then the guy in the blue shirt's like
yeah what are you doing later you
hanging out later you think you tried to
talk to her he definitely tried to talk
to her
because he wants her to believe that uh
uh
that they're of the same mindset
you know that they have the same sort of
viewpoints on things yeah so you punched
it i was i was gonna punch it too it's
like
so many people yeah yeah you know what
i was gonna punch it but i didn't want
to break it before everybody else got
their shots in because i punched so
[ __ ] hard
and this is what's wrong with people on
twitter who all think they're making a
point
to john alonso so you're okay with
making fun of some
fat guy but not outing racist who would
kill you both of you if they could
here's the the thing john that's all
we're doing is goofing on the guy
we're not trying to ruin his life right
we're not it's not that i'm against
outing racist i personally do think that
if you're a racist i'm fine with the a
people knowing who you are i think you
should be a man and state your public
opinion as yourself
what i'm saying is that that start
targeting the jobs like you should be
fired for that shitty opinion
so yeah i'm making fun of a fat guy who
did a lame kick in a public place
but we're not taking it any further
we're not trying to to hurt his life
right we're just laughing at how he
looked publicly there's a big difference
hey guys we're making fun of this fat
guy who can't kick statues good
here's his phone number and his name and
his family you guys go do it too
and let's get him fired yeah and let's
humiliate him as far as
the people of his life are getting like
the racist it's hard to feel bad for
racists like who are actively prote
because like i don't like what they
stand for i'm just saying as a public
principle
i don't like anybody even if their
principles are shitty
i don't like necessarily going let's get
them fired for having shitty opinions
although i will say if this guy does get
fired for kicking that statue
i will hire him as a professional statue
remover
i will tell you i think he's great i
think he's a terrific
statue remover yeah we actually like
this guy he's terrific
yeah i hope his personal information
gets out there because then we can talk
to him exactly i ask him to come over my
house hang out
yeah hey what do you think of this just
get us i want to just get this thing to
my house that needed knocking over
[Laughter]
could you kick that over there and it's
like a lead balloon embrace his little
fat foot
i want to get this guy's take on things
you know i just want to i want to find
out what his point of view on
on all kinds of different world views
are because he's definitely got
points of view on things he wants he
wants to be very special
you know yeah he does he wants to just
be a part of it he does want to be a
part of it
i would this is if if young jim norton
when he was drinking was a little bit uh
well a lot a bit fatter
you might have been a little more like
this kid oh yeah i i think this guy
captures who i was internally
right i was a dweeb who was always a day
late and a dollar short
and didn't want to hurt his hand
but he still wouldn't talk to so he's
probably he's going to find out where
that chick
was kicking the [ __ ] out of the statue
he's going to find out where she lives
and later on tonight he's just gonna
walk by her house playing uh iron man
in a boom box he really is i i am no
better than him i am him
yeah but you know the south it's funny
he is us people that would knock him in
the south
during this interview yesterday for the
uh the the history of comedy they asked
me about when you do the south
well they said to me when you do do we
talk about material and i raised the
point that people think you change
material when you go to different places
and i did north carolina and all this
stuff and like i didn't change my
material for the south like people think
that like the the south is not some
hay siege who you have to change
everything for and dumb it down
so our opinion of the south is not bad
that's the kind of point i'm making is
that
as a performer i don't have any
different opinion of southern audiences
as i do northern audiences
the northern audiences are no smarter
than the southern audiences than a
[ __ ] hipper
no you know maybe a little more religion
in the south and that's it
but in the north there's a little more
of that sort of like yeah
damn the man yeah man so our
impression of the south is not bad at
all to me this is just a part of it that
you should fix
dude that makes i i kind of hundred
percent about that no i agree i i
agree with you i think you're speaking
for both of us i don't have some shitty
outlook on you people in the south i've
performed down there a lot
what you mean you people you've been
great crowds
i love doing dallas i love doing houston
[ __ ] austin north carolina you're
great
i spent uh the first uh 16
julys of my life in paducah kentucky
i love it there
i like dicks
[Laughter]